[Musique]
r r r
[Applaudissements]
r nous sommes samedi 1er a il est 5h5
maintenant et malgré l'interdiction et
bien ce festival pop d'ex en Provence va
avoir lieu d'ors et déjà je vous
souhaite la
bienvenue après le défilé hindou du Rada
Krishna temple après Michel lanelow
l'animateur du festival le premier
groupe français il y en aura beaucoup
d'autres parmi les plus célèbres les
Wallas collection le rare bird mungo
Jerry Jimmy Winter et le Canadien
Léonard Cohen il a coûté à lui seul une
fortune plus de 30 millions d'anciens
francs pour certains c'est un scandale
et peut-être l'explication du déficit du
[Musique]
festival alors ce festival général il a
bien commencé et il est en plein cours
et vous êtes un peu fatigué non oh ben
on est touj un peu fatigué enfin je ne
CRA pas la fatigue mais il en plein
cours Vous vous avez vu le programme
artistique qui est un des plus beau
qu'on a réalisé au monde je pas la
comparaison ni avec white ni avec
Woodstock j'ai des formations qui sont
absolument égales sinon supérieures et
j'ai un public extrêmement nombreux
enthousiaste est-ce que est-ce que
l'ambiance est la même que dans les
festival de pop musique aux États-Unis
ou en Angleterre il y a l'ambiance est
exactement la même parce que ceux qui
aiment la pop musique et qui sont venus
pour la pop musique ont le même esprit
que ceux qui sont qui se réunissent à
Woodstock ou à White il y a quelque
chose qui vous plaît pas ici oui il y a
quelque chose qui me plaît pas
effectivement parce que la plupart du
monsieur je pas pas comment là le
général je sais pas comment a voulu à
tout prix montrer que il était très
gentil avec tout le monde qu'il a fait
ça pour le plaisir de la musique en fait
c'est pour le fruit qui fait qui fait ça
or ça on l'admet pas malheureusement
nous sommes dans un pays latin dans les
pays latin on aime un peu la discussion
alors vous avez vu je m'y prête alors il
y a des discussions des discussions avec
des jeunes gens ils ont des idées sur
unre de choses tout à fait normal que je
leur réponde on peut discuter savoir à
quelle est la finalité de la finalité de
de ce genre de chose et pour vous quelle
est-elle je pense que c'est d'arriver à
faire participer le plus grand nombre de
gens à la pop musique et vous ne trouvez
que il n'y a pas de monde parti 55 Fran
dans dans Comment entré je suis d'accord
qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui sont
rentrés gratuitement mais quand quand
une entrée tu à 55 francs je pense que
il y a beaucoup de gens qui peuvent pas
se payer
[Musique]
ça c'est une opinion pendant près de 3
jours pourtant beaucoup de jeunes gens
et de jeunes filles ont campé dormi à la
belle étoile jouer de la musique pour le
plaisir pour l'amitié cela n'est pas
exagéré de le dire encore une fois le
Domaine de Saint pon n'est pas Woodstock
il y a eu un peu d'agitation pourquoi
venu en France au festival de pop
musique parce que on aime la pop
musique vous allez dans tous les
festivals de pop
musique ang Angleterre c'est très
différent qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
celui-ci c'est triste
[Musique]
oui c'est vrai il y a eu un peu
d'agitation on a parlé un peu de
politique on a jeté de la boue sur notre
caméraman vous l'avez tout à l'heure
mais dans ce genre de réunion il y a
toujours une frange marginale de
dissidents cela dit il y en a beaucoup
plus qui aiment la
[Musique]
musiqueou
le triomphateur du festival c'est lui
mungo Jerry en tête des h par
actuellement il a vraiment soulevé la
foule à saon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dernier groupe pour nous le colosséum
ils sont anglais leur nom est le symbole
de l'entreprise que représente un
festival de pop musique
colossal
[Musique]